okay I'm recording this in the kitchen
because my neighbor is mowing the lawn
it's very loud so regardless a so first
thing you should know is that I love
chases so the fact this episode is
called the chase got me really excited
and what I like that this episode
captured it's not a particularly story
driven one it doesn't all tie to go to
the big story necessarily what it
captures though which i think is very
important in any long ongoing conflict
is the chaos of it because in chaos
there's often confusion and in confusion
there's surprisingly clarity because you
forget sometimes what the conflict is
and what you're fighting for and you are
reminded that you're all part of the
same species in a sense you should all
be on the same side and I like in this
episode through all this chaos going on
for people splitting up and constant
running through the night they never get
sleep and they start snapping at each
other and they start splitting up and
teaming up with other people they don't
even know and coming across strangers
and fighting duo's and trios and
whatever that would normally be hooked
up together they discover certain things
about what they're really looking for in
terms of who they will team up when the
chips are stacked against them or when
they need a friend or who their friends
are who will do what for who who will
not do what for who and again in episode
like this I think is a very smart
episode to have because you're actually
learning a lot about the characters
without necessarily going into their
backstory just seeing how they act - a
very long chaotic situation can really
demonstrate a lot so you have this great
setup where Sula and her Posse are
chasing after uh you know Aang and his
friends and they have some sort of new
device that you know it's like a
super-fast tank pretty much
it can track them almost anywhere they
don't know how so obviously it seems
like the Fire Nation is really helping
their technology more and more way which
is good makes threat even stronger so
you have that going on you have Tov is a
tougher tough I forget but you have her
splitting from the group for a bit
because she's talking about how she's
holding she's carrying her own weight
what's the problem and Katara's having
problem because she should be
contributing more to the team and be a
team player and obvious that's not as
much as you would think oh come on
that's obvious I actually think there is
a touch more going on there I've come
across that situation sometimes too it's
a legit situation so you know someone
that just says hey I'm doing my own
thing just let me do my own thing and
then others are like look this is a team
effort you have to be part of the team
you have to help out we'll help you and
so on so forth so I thought that was
actually a very legitimate going on
there you have the uncle meets up with
toph and they don't know that they're
going to be enemies essentially they
just run into each other they have no
idea who they are they're just two
strangers laws and they share tea
together and they have a conversation
what I really like about this is that
you could show them having the
conversation and that could be enough
you would have your message out there
that hey look these people don't know
who they are and yet they're getting
along because they don't know who they
are that's the message you know this is
the scene you know this scene that this
is what I think man is steel got wrong
oh why am I being so mean the Man of
Steel
I don't care um man is feel would show
these scenes because they know hey these
scenes are in development movies where
what does this mean while I have to do
this and now the scene where I get beat
up and now the scene where I'm having
trouble fitting in and now the scene
here but it doesn't just stop there it's
not just showing that scene for the sake
of showing that scene because there's a
part of the formula what they talk about
is important they talk about what it
means to not only help one another
but to allow themselves to be helped and
I love at the end when she's leaving she
gives that bit of advice to him which I
thought was very good advice that okay
so you're following your nephew because
you want him to know that he needs you
and you're aware of it and that option
should always be open you could let him
know that you need him as well I thought
that was very nice poignant writing I
thought that was very well done um so
again it's not just this scene is here
to be that scene you know just to get
across this one message is that they
actually are sharing a conversation that
an important good strong conversation so
it like it could stand on its own if it
didn't connect to the rest of the story
it would still be a good scene so kudos
for that and at the end you get this
wonderful Mexican standoff you you get
uh you get an you guys Zuko and you got
as Ulla and they have this three-way
financed really great but then they keep
adding stuff on top they have uh Katara
catches up and and Sokka and then you
have the uncle catches up and then you
have Tom catches up and this fight is
going and it just escalates and gets
more and more crazy and you're seeing
who in those moments you're they're just
trying to think very quickly okay who
whose side am I on again way away what
which one might find a way that's Duke
oh wait that's Azula okay I'm fighting a
duel wait who's Zuko fight is he going
up there Hey no he's gone okay we're all
after Azula and it's those moments are
so great because like I said you do get
this surprising amount of strange
clarity in these very confused chaotic
moments and even after when Azula does
that when she attacks the uncle I hope
he's not die I don't think he's dead I
don't think they would kill him off like
he'd had to have some last words or
something I don't think it would kill
him off right quite then I think he's
moaning - but I love that guitar goes up
and says Zuko I can help and he says get
away and it's like after that moment is
over they're back to their roles
and they're back to their sides but but
they did sort of share a jar they like
all the outcasts came together which I
like it's like for a second they all
shared that in common that they had a
common enemy it's what my brother and I
always call the alliance of convenience
where my enemy is going to become my
friend because he's also the enemy of my
other enemy and I love those scenes I
love when they have to give in and join
the lesser of two evils um so ah phones
ringing but I will answer it later
because I'm almost done here so I get a
good episode I would very much argue an
important episode you see something
called the chase you would just say oh
it's just a chase but so much is
revealed about the characters in not
necessarily showing their backstory or
just talking but just what they'll do
under pressure if at you could argue can
actually learn the most about a
character in those moments so I think
this was a very strong very important
episode and I love that he doesn't end
with Zuko talking to his uncle it
doesn't end with Azula say next time it
just ends with them sleeping I thought
that was a very good fast but also very
effective way of ending in it was so
quick you you could almost miss it but
it is just the episodes so chaotic and
so fast pace you do just take a breath
you just go oh and you feel that breath
you feel that need to you know for for
just relaxation just just to stop so
play a good way so a very very good
episode I enjoyed it immensely so that's
it for this one I'll see you the next
one